hi everyone um welcome welcome to the
class so topic for today the class is
labeled Advanced topics but really what
we'll be doing is we'll be looking at
expressive power of graph neural
networks and see whether that expressive
power uh can be uh can be improved or
increased um and uh the way we think of
right kind of a recap now back to graph
neural networks is that basically given
the input graph we were thinking about
these computation graphs and uh you know
we propagate information uh through
several several
layers and when we think of this is that
you know we have the input graph we have
the graph neural networks we obtain the
node embeddings and then you know we we
attach some prediction head to it to
make predictions uh you know we have the
evaluation metric we have the the loss
function um and so on right and um
today's lecture the key question We'll
be asking is can we make the
representation power uh of GNN more
expressive so really this is what um we
are going to talk about today so first I
want to highlight some limitations uh of
graph neural networks and then I'll show
you kind of two principles two solutions
uh uh to address them so uh here's kind
of what a perfect uh graph neural
Network would do right what should the
perfect graph neural network do right it
should provide me basically a k layer
perfect graph neural network would embed
a node based on the structure of the kop
neighborhood around that node right so a
perfect GNN would build an injective
function between the neighborhood
structure um and the embedding right so
every node should be mapped to a to a
unique or every Network neighborhood
should be mapped to a unique position um
in the embedding space and uh just kind
of to clarify for today's lecture I'm
really going to focus on the graph
structure and I'm going to kind of
ignore a bit node attributes right I
will assume that you know note features
are kind of uh the least informative and
things like that and I will really focus
on capturing the graph structure right
so what I'd like if if this is a
neighborhood of a node to hop
neighborhood each unique neighborhood
should map to a unique position in the
embedding space that would be the the
perfect GNN that would be the most
expressive GNN I could have right so
here's an example right uh for a perfect
GNN uh two nodes that um that have the
same network networking um neighborhood
structure should get the same embedding
so for example if I have two graphs and
I say what should be the embedding of V1
and what should be the embedding of V2
then these two nodes appear exactly in
the same graph so they will have the
same embedding right again let's uh
assume uh let's let's kind of don't
worry too much about node features right
but what I want is these two nodes
appear in the same network structures so
um I will give them the same uh the same
embedded okay and right if two nodes
have different neighborhood structures
then they should get different
embeddings right node V1 appears in a
different network than V3 so the
embeddings should differ right we kind
of all agree right if we focus only on
the network structure I want the
embeddings here to be different because
I want to distinguish the difference and
here the embeddings will be the same
because the network structure is the
same so all sounds good um however um
this may not always be the case
especially this this is the the second
uh the second one is what we what we
care about right um and uh even though
if two nodes have the same neighborhood
structure sometimes maybe we want to
assign different emings to them and I'll
give you an example of that um and
because nodes that appear in different
for example the reason for this is for
nodes that appear in different positions
of the graph and I'll explain what I
mean by that and we are going to call
this position aware tasks and I'll talk
about a class of graph neural networks
called position aware graph neural
networks uh what's an example of a
position aware task
imagine you live in Manhattan Manhattan
looks like this to you a graph neural
network won't know whether you are in
this corner or in that corner because
the network neighborhood around both of
these looks about the looks the same
right still you'd like to know that you
are at the bottom left of um I know
Southwest of Manhattan or in the
northeast of Manhattan right and by
Manhattan I mean you know it's a grid um
again and assume no note features right
so so that's what I mean by position
aware right and a graph neural network
will give you the same embedding for
these two nodes even though they are on
the opposite sides of the
network um and then also the second
observation is about different network
structures which we would like to map
into different uh different embeddings
right um in next lecture nine right when
we talked about how powerful are graph
neural networks we discussed that the
expressive power of gnns is upper
founded by the expressive power of the
vice filer Layman graph isomorphism test
um and one simple example where this
breaks is for example GNN cannot count
the cycle lend right if you are a node
on a cycle of length three or you are a
node on a cycle of lengths four your
computation graphs will be the same
right you are a node you have to
neighbors each of the neighbors has two
neighbors and you can go make this as
deep as possible but the computation
graphs between V1 and V2 will be the
same so the GNN won't be able to
distinguish uh these two Network
structures again I'm not assuming any
node features or attributes that would
help me with this so the plan for
today's lecture is to look into these
two kind of observations or issues one
is the uh observation number one where
we want
nodes even though they have the same
network structure around them we want
them to be embedded in different uh in
different uh points this is called
position aare graph neural networks and
then the second one which says that the
graph neural network cannot count the
size of the cycle um I'll talk about a
very simple idea called identity aware
graph neural networks that actually
allows you to increase the expressive
power of the g&n so those are that's the
that's the plan for the lecture and if
we have time I'll I'll briefly mention a
a bonus Topic at the end okay that's the
that's the plan so uh here is our
approach and how we are kind of going to
think for the rest of the lecture right
the idea is that given two different
inputs um uh uh uh you know we we think
of them as being labeled differently and
we'll say that you know kind of a failed
model will always assign the same
embedding to these different inputs and
a successful model will assign different
embeddings to these different inputs
right um and the the the key kind of
reasoning that we are going to do is to
to realize that the embedding created by
the GNN is determined by the computation
graph right so here I have two nodes V1
and vs2 and imagine that V1 is labeled
with uh label a and V2 is labeled by
label B the goal now is that I want to
do let's say note classification and in
order for me to classify this one in one
class and classify the other one in the
other class this means that the
embeddings of these two notes have to be
different right so um how but will will
this uh will this will this actually
happen and as I was uh showing you uh
earlier this may uh actually um not
happen right if I I'll show you I ignore
these zeros and ones for now but imagine
I have two different uh Cycles um and
all all the nodes have no features or
all the features are the same so so
their computation graphs will be exactly
the same so the embedding of V2 is going
to be the same as the embedding of V1 so
you won't be able to distinguish between
them so you won't be able to classify
one into class A and the other one in
class B you either classify both
basically they will be assigned the same
class so what would be a naive solution
to this one naive solution uh you know
kind of I would say you know it's a the
warning is don't actually try this
because because it's naive but you know
to give you a flavor would be that we
can assign each node a different ID then
we can always differentiate between
different nodes so I could say you know
this is my node one this is my node two
and this is my node let's say four right
I just using this one hot indicator to
label to to to to account for the nodes
right and now everything everything
becomes uh distinguishable because this
one has neighbors um you know the one at
the last spot and the one with the
second spot and this one has Neighbors
at the second spot and the second spot
so uh you know we are able um we are
able to uh to distinguish to distinguish
this okay so um this would be one
possible way to say okay now I can
actually distinguish uh these two uh
these two nodes and as I'm looking at
this here's actually a bug right it
should be uh no it's not a bug it's all
good okay I'm just um maybe yeah didn't
see well okay great so that's uh that's
one way how you could try to distinguish
these things the issue is that now you
need uh a one hot encoding for every
node so the dimensionality of the of
every no of every node will be will be
proportional to the size of the graph
which is unvisible and it's not
inductive right I cannot generalize this
to new graphs I don't know how to label
or how to assign these IDs to new graphs
so this is why this is a bad
idea but let me tell you now how um one
possible solution to this that's called
position aware graph neural networks
okay um that are that are going to uh to
solve for this and here is how we think
of this right imagine that kind of
generally speaking there are two types
of tasks like again just you know um
approximately um two extreme types of
task in let's say no classification in
the graph one is what you could call or
what we call structure aware tasks which
and this would be a structure aware
labeling of the node right like no these
two these two nodes are are um um uh you
know have the same network structure
around them so they get the same class
these two nodes uh have the same network
structure around them so they get the
same class so this would be like
structure aware labeling just as an
example right and here is a position
aware typ right nodes here on the left
are labeled with a and notes on the
right are labeled with
B right um and the point is the
following right for structure aware
tasks um you know the computation graph
of node of nodes labeled with a is going
to be different than the computation
graph of nodes labeled with B right
because here he has three neighbors this
node has two neighbors so that's already
a difference so the g&n will be able to
distinguish between these two and and uh
GNN will work beautifully and you'll be
able to learn this
classification okay all good right um
how about the position aware uh labeling
of the graph right here's this what I
would call position aware labeling of
the graph so let's take you know this
note labeled with a and let's this take
that other note labeled with B let's
look at their computation graphs
actually computation graphs are
identical and you can go as deep in this
computation graphs as you want they will
still be identical right because the two
uh the two nodes their positions are are
are isomorphic to each other right so um
the the V1 and V2 will always have the
same computational graph due to the
structure symmetry so um the question
becomes is there a what could I do so
that my GNN would be more expressive and
would be able to capture this difference
between nodes A and B and learn that you
know one one set of nodes should be
labeled one way and the other set of
nodes should be labeled the other way
okay so that's the that's a question we
are trying to address to make um gnn's
work with this kind of graph uh labeling
task okay so the key concept that I'm
going to introduce right is is the
notion of an anchor okay so we are going
to have this notion of an anchor and
then we are going to generalize it to
the notion of the anchor set okay um the
idea of the anchor is that anchor gives
you like a reference point right the
problem with graphs is that there is no
reference point so you don't know in
what part of the graph you are so
anchors will provide us reference points
right so the idea is that I'm going to R
in in this case let's say randomly pick
a node let's call it S1 and I'll Define
that that's an anchor node so now um I
will be able to represent positions V1
V2 um as some kind of how their
positions relate with respect to the
location of the anchor right so in some
sense what we are going to do is we are
going to develop some kind of positional
encoding uh in the graph so that nodes
understand where in the graph they
reside that's the that's another way to
say what we are doing right so anchor
serves as a reference point point um and
can be used to basically locate or
Define the position of the node in the
graph so if this is my anchor then for
example and let's say I quantify the
distance using the shortest path then V1
is one step away from the anchor V2 is
two steps away from the anchor right so
now if I would um use this as positional
encoding as a property of the node then
the neural network would able to
distinguish these two nodes because they
are at different distances from the
anchor okay
um and to make the entire thing more uh
more robust is we can pick even more
anchors we can have one anchor here's
the second one and uh the observation is
that more anchors can better
characterize node's position in
different regions of the graph so we
want to have many anchors and now we
have kind of multi-dimensional
positional encoding of the node uh in
the
graph the what turns out to be also very
very useful
and I'll show you some theory behind it
is that we can generalize this notion of
an anchor to a notion of an anchor set
where an anchor set is a set of nodes
and now a distance of the node to the
Anchor set is the is the minimum
distance of the Noe to any member of the
of the anchor set okay it's like it's
like what's my distance to the closest
to the closest anchor it's like what's
my distance to the closest petrol
station and there's a lot of petrol
stations around Okay so um why is this
helpful because lar large anchor sets
sometimes may provide more precise uh
position uh estimation um and we can
save on the total number of anchors
right so for example here I denoted it
here that s the this S3 right so this
would be node S1 and V3 is a size two
anchor set and now the position the
encoding would be for example V3 is part
of the anchor set so it has distance
zero to it while we1 has distance one to
the Anchor set right um and the point is
that if I would only have anchors S1 and
S2 they cannot differentiate in my case
nodes V1 and V2 um but this multi this
kind of bigger anchor sets where I I
choose the distance to the closest one
uh allow me to to better differentiate
um why you know why do you do this this
way there's actually a very good
theoretical mathematical motivation uh
to do that right uh the way you can
think of this is the following I'll I'll
kind of paraphrase a bit of math here to
give you the intuition what we want to
do is we want to um embed Matrix space
um of uh vertices and uh a distance
function into the ukian space into K
Dimension ukian space such that the
original distance metric uh is preserved
right so it means for every not PAAD UV
the ukian embedding distance between
their embeddings is we want it to be
close to their original distance uh in
the network okay um and then there is a
beautiful theorem that kind of keeps
popping up over and over again it's
called Ban's theorem and here is what
bgan says kind of informally right
imagine that I am considering the
following embedding function so the
embedding of a node is simply the
minimum distance of the note to the
first anchor set to the second anchor
set and I I sample uh uh log n um and I
I sample anchor sets where the size of
the an where the first index is the um
is the number of anchor sets of a given
size and the second index is the size of
the anchor set right um and uh um here
uh C is a con an sij is chosen to
include each node in uh in uh
independently with probability one over
uh uh two to the 2 to the I so it
basically means that as I'm as I'm um as
I'm sampling uh um Big um as I'm
sampling uh smaller anchor sets um they
basically as I go more to the to the
right uh my I is going to increase so
the pro so the anchor sets are are going
to get exponentially smaller but there
is going to be exponentially more of
them okay um and here in my case the
distance between the node and the and
the given anchor set is the minimum
distance between the the node V and any
member of the anchor set um and what
what's the point of all this the the
point is if you construct your anchor
sets the following way way then the
embedding distance produced by this
embedding f is probably close to the
original distance metric that's kind of
the the key this is why we care about
this um what is happening here is
basically that we are generating
multiple anchor sets of bigger and
bigger sizes but having fewer and fewer
of them right so we we are going to have
a lot of anchor sets of size one uh um
fewer anchor sets of size two even fewer
anchor sets of size three and so on but
we are going kind of to have this uh um
many of them with increasing sizes but
with decreasing numbers of them so that
and and if that is the that is that is
happening then uh the following fact is
true yes so like how is this eding
different from not so also like someing
for good question so the question is how
is the no this dis embedding different
uh for um from note toac um you know
note toac
the the the intuition there was to
predict this um neighborhoods and what I
showed you in terms of theoretical
properties no toac kind of boils down to
a particular Matrix
factorization uh approach of a
particularly transformed your graph
adjacency Matrix right I think I showed
you some ugly fat equation right um here
this is different this was actually the
the Boran theorem was actually is
usually usually de was developed for um
Vector spaces right and here I'm
rephrasing it in terms of the graph but
the idea is that basically if you have a
high dimensional space then you can
basically Define a set of anchors in
this High dimensional space determine
your Lo position according to those
anchors and the distances are going to
be preserved so this is much more kind
of geometric intuition okay uh yes in
practice doesn't matter what we take
from the doesn't
matter uh good question so the question
is what what do we what do we pick for D
what people like to pick in graphs is
the shortest path distance you could
also do some kind of more random walk
distance or something like that um that
that you would Thrive I mean this will
depend on the um uh on the on the
application but I think the
point
being um yeah good good good good
question I think uh the point is that
this distance has to be that distance
right so these two distances have to be
kind of compatible okay yes so if I want
to multiple different graph into a reor
space does it matter each of the graph
at the same consistent anchor selections
or I can have a different type of anchor
SL for each of the different great
question uh so what you were asking me
about if I have multiple graphs multiple
anchor sets what do I do um let me
address that later because what you are
really asking me is you know this kind
of inductive versus transductive because
as soon as you define an anchor set you
have forced yourself to pick a set of
nodes and and that's problematic I will
I'm going to address that
okay um so
um the the motivation for definition
development of the position of RGN is
basically follows this uh Boran theorem
right where basically the idea is that
we are going to uh um sample um some uh
uh uh logarithmic number squared uh of
anchor sets and then embed each node
based on the distances uh to these
anchor sets um and what then becomes
harder and this is exactly the question
you were asking me is you know how do
you maintain um inductive capability how
can you generalize from one graph to
another graph because nodes are
different anchor sets will be different
and the way this is solved in the paper
is that during training new anchor sets
are resampled every time so you kind of
make this anchor sets uh move around and
the position of RG andn is learned to
operate over over new anchor sets um and
at the test time when given a new uh
graph you can simply kind of sample
anchor sets um at random um what is um
to summarize what is
important is that when you represent um
the the positional information we
represent node by its positions to
randomly selected anchor sets and each
dimension of the position is tied now to
the uh to a given uh to a given uh
anchor set now how do you use positional
information I would say the following if
you are inside one graph and you are
learning like in a more kind of
semi-supervised uh setting way then a
simple way is to use this positional
encoding as an simple augmented note
feature to add this additional
information to the to the GNN to be able
to learn and that works really well in
the in the kind of uh
semi-supervised uh learning where you
are given one graph and the anchor sets
can be fixed now if you want to the
issue with this is that each dimension
of the position is tied to a particular
anchor set so um dimension of the
positional encode in kind of cannot be
changed or randomly permuted without
changing its
meaning so the the position of our graph
neural networks paper actually develops
a special neural network that can
maintain this permutational invariant
property of positional of positional
encodings and permuting the input
feature Dimension will only result in
the permutation of the uh output uh
output Dimension uh and this means that
the value of but the value of each
Dimension won't change and you know more
details are in the position aware um
graph neural networks paper but the idea
is the following right if I look at my
distance towards all size one anchor
sets then if I have sampled enough size
one anchor sets then of course I sample
them in different order but kind of my
distribution of distances to them will
kind of be unchanged if I mean a given
part of the graph right kind of in in in
the limit right so that's that when I
say this permutation invariant I want to
be basically I want my positional
encoding to depend on the anchor set
size but not the exact locations or
positions or the order in which I
sampled uh the anchor sets that's you
know further details um in this uh in
this paper yes can you go back to slides
one two oh sorry to the slide that
has function
uh yes just clarification question if we
use the vetting function that is
described there uh the application of
this is that it's only used in the first
layer we we initialize our node features
with that Vector right yes so again one
like let's make a difference between
what the Burgan is saying and then what
we are what we are doing uh what what
ban is saying if you are embedding your
your nodes the following way and if you
are embedding them in a space that has
the logari logarithmic uh uh size with
the number of nodes which is great right
exponentially smaller Dimension than the
number of nodes then your distances will
be preserved we we we don't care like in
some sense in the position of RG andn we
don't care about preserving distances we
care about correct classif ification
right so we have a bit different goal um
and this is not the embedding function
we are using we learn a we learn a graph
neural network to learn the embedding
because we want to do Downstream
prediction but the our choice of um
anchor sets and why we like them is
because is motivated by the Boran
theorem right so it's not that that uh
you know Boran is a motivation it's an
an abstract motivation not a we don't
follow it strictly so that's a good
that's a good point sorry if that was
confusing yes when you if you go back to
where we are forward in the slides um
where you say that this is exerted like
for forward again um still more forward
yeah okay so is this saying essentially
that the distances to the Anchor nodes
for each individual ver text it sort of
like follows the same distribution each
time you relabel the an not so like that
distribution is sort of in varant that's
basically the idea exactly right if I if
I sample I know if I'm in a graph and I
sample 100 different nodes and I look my
distribution of distances to those yeah
that distribution you be quite stable
regardless of which specific hund hund I
mean 100 again is is you know I I pull
that number out of my out of the head of
course it will you know depend but kind
of that's the idea that that kind of
stabilizes
based on the structure of the graph
right yeah I haven't been able to get my
head around why you might want sets of
differ sies why don't you just always
want an anchor set of size
one uh that's a good that's a good
question so the question is why is it
better to uh have um uh sets anchor sets
of bigger sizes why not always sets of
size one um the point is the following
right is like um
the the anchor set of a bigger size will
require you one dimension in your
positional encoding but in Pro in some
sense it will provide much more uh
information because the variance of that
will be smaller right because you can
think of that that it's that's Define
some kind of boundary and you just say
how far away from the border am I right
so it kind of it's a different type of
an object that you are measuring your
distance to right so good yes
good question so the question is uh
would in some applications be good to to
maybe not sample anchor sets uh uh
randomly and engineer them I I would say
I would say yes if you have a good
reason why again the reason we do it
randomly is because then you are kind of
I don't have to say anything about what
data you do it right and again um um you
can yeah you could I know for molecules
it might be interesting to be more
strategic what are you going to choose
Okay cool so that that finishes the
discussion of my first point which was
this position of a encoding of nodes so
that a node nodes knows what part of the
graph it it it belongs to so that it can
determine its embedding its label based
based on the region of the graph they
belong to and not necessarily based on
the exact neighborhood structure that
they have so that was the the intuition
here so let's now talk about the second
uh issue which we said that uh right in
position aware we say even though nodes
have the same network structure around
them we want them to be um embedded in
different places now we are going to
look at what is called identity aware um
graph neural networks and the point here
is that I want notes that appear in
different structures to actually be
embedded differently so right um so far
right the summary is that we we learned
that GNN would fail for position of our
task and we develop the position of RGN
with positional encoding that allows us
to fix that problem right uh then the
question is can GNN perform perfectly on
structure of Earth task uh and the
answer is no right why is the answer no
is because uh gnn's kind of exhibit um
failure uh cases at structure aware
tasks at all different you know at node
level Edge level and graph level because
graphs can be highly
symmetric and the WL test uh is going to
fail and I gave you this example where I
have two nodes V1 and V2 in obviously in
different graphs but if I look at the
the shape the structure of the GNN
computation graph which we established
in lecture N9 that basically this is
this is based on how the embedding of
the node gets created and if the two uh
the the two computation graphs are
identical are isomorphic then the
embedding of the two nodes is going to
be identical so there's no way for us to
distinguish them or to assign them to
different classes right so this is for
example for node classification tasks
you could do I can show you examples
also for link prediction tasks right
imagine I have a um node zero and then I
have nodes V1 and V2 um and
um uh the question the question is right
um uh can I can I differentiate between
you know v0 linking to node V1 but not
linking to node V2 again node V 0 will
have some embedding but V1 and V2 have
the same computation graphs so they'll
have the same impairing so I will either
predict that V 0 links to both V1 uh and
V2 or that they it links to none of them
right again I cannot my embedding won't
distinguish V1 and V2 so there will be
no way for us to say V Zer links to one
to one but not the other okay and then
how about at the graph level graph at
graph level um it's it's also becomes
quite uh quite interesting right if I
have two different uh input
graphs but uh um but I but if I if I
look at their computation graphs again
they'll be identical so even at the
graph embedding level these two
different graphs will be embedded into
the same point so we won't be able to
classify them uh differently okay so
that's kind of a set of issues uh with
GNN again if if you don't have no
attributes that would allow you to
distinguish this right many times you'll
be I know you'll be lucky or I don't
know like you have good node attribut
and then things start to work out but
without know the attributes and just
focusing on the graph structure um uh um
you you GNN suffer from these problems
um so here's an
idea idea is very is very simple it's
basically the idea is to have inductive
note coloring right you know we can
assign a color to the note we want to
embed right if I want to do things
inductively then I always know who who
is the node that I care about right that
that is the root of my computation graph
right so what if I label that node and
kind of I treat that node uh differently
specially right so you know let's say
here the the yellow orange node is my uh
the node we want to embed and then um
the the white nodes are the rest of the
nodes right so um then if you look at
this then the computation graph is going
to look like that right I'm going to
remember when the computation graph
visits the the the the colored node
right so here I go to the two neighbors
and then the two
neighbors here one one one goes back and
one goes here so I'm here and so on and
so forth right so this is now my
computation graph um and here's a comp
computation graph uh for um if I if I
kind of show you the identities of the
nodes all right but notice now that I
have a bit more interesting pattern here
that GNN could capture because it knows
the color of the node and uh and
assigning a color to the node of
interest is inductive in a sense I can
transfer the model to a new graph
because there's always a a whenever I I
embed I know what node I'm trying to
embed okay so uh the point is this
coloring is inductive it is in invariant
to the node ordering or identities of
the nodes I can re uh relabel the nodes
I can reum them but the structure the
shape of this computation graph and the
pattern of white versus orange is going
to stay uh going to stay the same right
so here I have 1 two 3 here I have 1 two
3 but the sh the but the the color
pattern in the computation graph Remains
the Same that's uh you know it's kind of
trivial but it's important okay so uh
that's the first one right so I have now
an inductive
capability how about does this increase
my um predictive power um and it does
right because um if I take now the two
the two graphs the triangle and a square
and uh I do not classification and I do
and I say okay what is now the
computation graph for V1 versus vs2 it
will actually be
different right because this is for V1
we already worked it out but for v2 it
it will be different right I'm going
from from U V2 to Neighbors from
Neighbors I go either back to V1 or I go
to the next to the to the next neighbor
here but from here on I don't I don't
get to V2 again so at this level the the
pattern is different so my GNN if it
accounts for the color as well will be
able to distinguish these two notes so
basically I'm in some sense able now to
count the length of the cycle because I
see when does the GNN kind of come back
to where it started right and I see here
it comes back in in in in three steps
while here it will need four steps right
at this level I'm like at this level I'm
going to see only empty nodes um sorry
white nodes and then here I'll start
seeing orange nodes
again and if you use this kind of simple
uh simple trick then uh things start to
work work out very nicely here is for
graph classification A and B even though
computation graphs will have the same
structure the the the identity of the
starting node is going to to to make
this pattern be different uh from the
other pattern so I'll be able to uh
distinguish uh node a from node uh from
node B right and when I say ident why do
I call this class of models identity
aware um because because because it's
aware of the identity of the node that
we want to uh that we want to embed
right um and this is my last example
which is about uh um link prediction and
I'm trying to create an embedding for V1
and I want to try it for v2 and again if
I look at the computation graphs they're
going to differ at two levels right when
I go from V1 I go to the neighbor and
neighbor of neighbor and I can visit v0
while if I start at V2 I'm not able to
visit v0 in uh in two hops so because
these two computation graphs are are
different these two nodes are going to
be embedded in um in different uh in
different positions and I'll be able to
say you know link a occurs but link B
does not occur or something like that
right um so that's uh that's the that's
the idea uh that I wanted um to to
convey kind of at in an ract way about
this uh
um about this uh uh being able to
differentiate between different nodes by
using this simple kind of very cute idea
of of a labeling the starting node the
node of Interest now what I want to do
next is actually show you how to build a
GNN using this type of uh Noe coloring
okay that's that's what I want to show
to you um so I want to now show you how
to build a graph neural network actually
its architecture and how to take account
into these note colors when when we are
doing propagation and the idea is that
we are going to do heterogeneous uh
message passing right I generally
normally GNN applies the same message
aggregation computation function to all
the neighbors to all the nodes right um
so um right in a sense that g at GNN
layer we apply the same message
aggregation to each uh children or to
each node below
us what we are going to do in a g ID GNN
is that we are going to do heterogeneous
Ming message passing heterogeneous in a
sense that different types of message
passing are applied to different nodes
so ID GNN will apply apply a different
message aggregation function to nodes of
different colors and I only have nodes
of you know orange and white but that's
already good right so I'm going to apply
a different uh aggregation or
transformation here then I apply it to
uh to uh White nodes so at a given layer
different message aggregations is going
to applied based on the color the color
of the uh the color of the Noe um so to
to be a bit more uh formal and precise
like H is our node embedding um and
let's say that I first extract the K hop
computation graph here I'll label it
with G raised to the power
K and then I'm given some set the
initial note features um at level at
layer uh at layer uh zero right that's
that's the input and now the way my
aggregation is going to go is the
following right for uh now I'm going for
um uh all the nodes in the computation
graph and I'm um depend I'm aggregating
the follow I have a message function
that is going to change depending
whether the the uh node of Interest s is
the is the starting node sorry depending
the node of interest uh V is uh is equal
to the center node to the node of
Interest or not and we are going to use
different neural network functions to
transform the uh to to transform the
embeddings right so the the color uh
gets considered here right the root gets
a different the root node the node of
Interest gets a different color so it
gets to have a different uh message
function it means it gets to have
different uh
parameters right so why does this
heterogeneous message passing uh
work suppose I have two noes that have
the same computational graph structure
but have different not colorings since
we apply different neural network
embedding computation their embeddings
are also going to be different right
here I'm going to apply message function
a to all of these nodes while here I'm
going to apply a different message
function uh B to this nodes so the
messages are going to be different and
neural network will be able uh to
capture that difference yes is it
possible that the L function won't
transfer any information such that the
weights that are developed by A and B
are actually any different right like is
there a case where the note coloring
would be useful and so this
heterogeneous Mass message passing would
just sort of like wash out uh good
question so you are saying if I you know
train this heterogeneous neural network
um I initialize with some random
parameters this guy I initialize with
some random parameters that guy why why
wouldn't just both neural networks
converge to the same to the same thing
and I think the the you know the the
answer is they they might but they won't
if the the identity information is
important because nodes have different
labels even though they they live on
different Cycles so it depends on how
the labels are if the labels if the
labels are such that the cycle end
doesn't matter then it's okay for it to
converge to the same thing but if if we
want to distinguish then these things
won't shouldn't converge won't converge
to the same thing yes so do we have a
different message for each node the do
we have a different message no I mean
what do you mean we have a different
node different neuronet a c no no no we
just have two one is for white and one
is for yellow that's it I have just two
kind of neural I have just two message
functions message functions that I'm
applying to this nodes and message
functions that I'm applying to those
notes happy how many can we
add I just have two colors right I only
know who the root is and everyone else
looks the same to me yeah it's just two
yes just connecting this position is one
way of thinking about this gen similar
to if the the node we're embedding is
just theor node is that a way of
thinking about what it means in
color interesting so you are saying is
uh is uh thinking of the color the same
as thinking about U the
anchor uh not really not really right in
the anchor it's more like with the
anchor the intuition was where where in
the where am I positioned am I you know
in the East or am I in the west here you
are more asked how do I embed in my in
my local network structure and this is a
more expressive way to capture the local
Network structure right so so this is
all about the Lo the locality so it's
very kind of microscopic or mesoscopic
view while the the position of air was
much more kind of macroscopically where
am I roughly situated in the graph so
these two are kind of
orthogonal or complementary and you can
apply you could kind of apply both right
because they kind
of solve orthogonal
problems okay okay okay good good uh
super anything
else okay so let's let's uh um just to
explain you know so what's the
difference between GNN and an ID GNN the
difference is here right in the GNN the
computation graphs will be identical in
the ID GNN the computation graphs are uh
structurally um equivalent but uh I I
can account through this heterogeneous
message pass for the for the identity of
the node for having this special uh
orange node um and this will give me
more expressive power so why does ID GNN
kind of generally out outperform GNN
because ID GNN can count Cycles
originating from a given starting note
but the GNN cannot right and if if this
information turns out to be important
then this um the idnn allows you to uh
capture it right
um right so what you could also uh do
rather than having this heterogeneous
message passing you can actually on this
intuition of cycle lens you could
actually create like
a feature Vector uh for nodes to
actually count uh count Cycles right so
we would have a fast version of this
idea where you include identity
information as an augmented note feature
um and no need to do a heterogeneous
messing message function uh message
passing and you could use cycle counts
at each layer as an augmented no note
feature um and then use this with any
GNN okay so this would be you know V1
appears in a cycle of
um length uh zero um uh this is length
uh one this would be uh two three um and
and and so on right so um that would be
another way to uh to kind of bring in
similar intuition but then uh not change
the uh architecture so let me summarize
this part uh so ID GNN is a general um
extension of the GNN framework where we
can apply the ID GNN to any message
passing GNN right you could use a gcn
convolutional layer a graph Sage
convolutional layer a gene convolutional
layer however you would like right um
and GNN idnn will allow you to basically
build more
expressive graph neural network for both
node Edge and graph level
tasks the reason why ID jnn is more
expressive is because uh um it takes
care of this uh identity node and allows
you to basically have this special node
and account it for it in the message p
ing so basically now you have a graph
neural network that is more expressive
than the WL so the vice filer lemon
graph isomorphism test um and it's easy
to implement and actually uh P I know
implements it DGL I think also
implements it um and so on yes question
what is the one WL versus like a
3wl um the the one WL versus uh multiple
WL is uh how dimensional colors are you
using and how many hash functions are
you using
Okay um uh so the bigger this number the
more expressive the test
is okay uh cool so um maybe what I want
or is there any more
questions no no yes can we just think
like this graph as a ketogene graph like
my the like myself is like like
type one and like all other not is type
two and we something like RN on that uh
so you are saying can I uh can I use can
I think of your graph as a heterogeneous
graph that with two types of nodes type
one and type two and then run an rgcn on
top of it yes you can exactly that's
that's the sole point of all this you
could also use an rgcn that will be even
a bit slower but we'll achieve the same
goal yeah yeah Okay cool so uh good
point good point um great Let Me Maybe
um finish the lecture today with
um kind of a bit more of a discussion
and an introduction about how would you
think of robustness of graph neural
networks um and uh uh the motivation is
right um what would be what would how
robust are graph neural networks
especially how robust are they against
adversarial attacks um and this line of
research was actually motivated
especially in by by the research in
computer vision where basically you can
take you know you can ask a conu neur
network what is this and it will say
pandas now you add this type of noise to
it so you get this image and here it
will say it's a
gibbon okay and to me this looks like
that okay so the point is that an
adversary can come in add just little
kind of
carefully decided noise or uh changes to
the pixel values that are going
completely throw off your classifier and
what looks like Panda gets confused for
for for a banana or some crazy thing
okay so um uh these adversarial examples
the idea is that you know somebody body
carefully calculates this you know noise
or this uh perturbation and that small
perturbation can really flip your uh
classifier and this was first discovered
in 2015 for convolutional neural
networks right so the adversarial
examples are also um sometimes reported
in natural language processing similar
similar problems um as well as in audio
where again small carefully crafted
change can really throw off the
classifier and what this means is that
the existence of these adversarial um
examples prevents in some sense reliable
deploying of deep learning models
because an adversary can come in and get
any classification result they want by
just small manipulation right
adversaries may try to actively hack the
Deep learning model the model
performance can become much worse than
what we expect um and uh for this reason
deep learning models are often not
robust right um and it's this is a very
active uh area uh area of research to
think about robustness and this what
they call distribution
shifts so the question is how would you
generalize these Notions to uh uh to to
the to the graphs um and the why is this
important right because the common
applications of GNN usually you know are
on public social network uh uh play um
uh uh venues or it's about you know
Banking and transactions and so on so
there's a lot of monetary uh interests
from search engine social networks
recommander systems and um you know
adversaries have the incentive to
manipulate the underlying model uh and
try to hack the predictions uh the
predictions of it right if you are in a
search engine you want to be ranked as
high as possible if you are in a
recommender system maybe you want when
you are a seller you want your your uh
uh product to be recommended to as many
users as possible so you get more sales
there's a lot of gaming happening all
the
time so what I want to uh introduce to
you is kind of a framework how to think
about this for graph neural networks so
we want to study the robustness of gnns
uh we are going to consider uh the
following setting the task will be semi
supervised node classification so the
graph is partially labeled
and we want to complete the labeling of
the graph um and the model is we are
going to use the simplest gcn to do this
okay so the road map for the next 20
minutes is that you want to First
describe several real world uh attack
possibilities then then I will quickly
show the gcn model um that we are going
to uh attack uh so we know our opponent
that's that's important and then I'll
I'll formalize the the attack problem as
an optimization problem and then I'll
show you some empirical results okay so
that's the
idea so if you are attacking a graph
what can you attack uh you can either
attack uh um you can we have the the
target node this is the note for which
the model will be making a prediction
and uh we are going to call this node a
Target node and then we are going to
talk about attacker nodes which is the
which are the nodes to which attacker
has access and attacker can modify these
nodes okay that's the
idea now um what can an attacker um uh
modify there we can talk about a direct
attack where the attacker node is also
the target node and the the attacker can
modify the target node by you know
changing its features right um and it
can also change who the target node is
connected to okay um which means it can
add connections or it can remove
connections right it could cut a link it
could add a link or it could change the
features of the uh of the target node so
that's one attack possibility uh and we
call this a direct attack because we are
attacking directly the node the node of
interest there is also a more sneaky
indirect attack right in an indirect
attack the the target node is different
from the from the nodes that attackers
are attacking right so so the what can
the attacker do basically for this uh
attacker notes Here in blue the attacker
can change their features the attacker
can add connections or the attacker can
break connections like similar but now
to the nodes that are not the one for
which we care to uh flip its label okay
so um what's the objective function of
the attacker the attacker wants to
maximize the change of the node of the
target nodes label change the prediction
subject to small graph manipulation okay
so um the intuition being if graph
manipulation is too too large um maybe
um we will be easily
detected um so the successful attacks
should change the target prediction with
kind of unnoticeably small graph
manipulation right so the idea is I want
to flip the label of this node maybe I
do you know maybe I add an edge maybe I
I flip some attribute and all of the
sudden I get a completely different um
prediction right
so after after the attack maybe I want
the probability of class three to
increase but probability of class two to
decrease or something like that that
could be my goal so the way you can um
formalize this is the following let a be
the adjacency Matrix of the original
graph and X be the feature Matrix the
features of the nodes and after the
attack we are going to have a different
adjacency Matrix a prime and a different
um uh feature Matrix X Prime and our
what we would like to do what the
attacker wants to do is to make this
perturbation this attack as small as
possible so um we want graph
manipulation to be small
um um and here again graph manipulation
could either be direct changing the N
the connections of the target node or we
can be in indirect attack where the
attacker is attacking
nontarget uh Noe um so that's the first
thing to say so the way we are going to
formalize this is the following we are
going to say we have the original
adjacency Matrix original features and
node labels y we we are going to have
some model parameters learned our a X
and Y so our graph features and the
labels um and uh let's C be the class
label of node V predicted by the gcn
with those uh parameters now we assume
that the attacker has access to the
graph features and the um uh and the uh
labels as well as the learning algorithm
and what the attacker can modify the
attacker can modify the graph and the
attacker can modify uh the
features now if the attacker makes this
modification we will we we would
unknowingly learn a different model a
model SATA star Prime um that is now
learned on the mo on the attacked graph
attacked features but with the still the
original uh labels all right and now I'm
going to use this C star Prime to denote
the class label of a not V under this uh
different model and the goal of the
attacker is to flip the label of that
node V right that the that the labeling
under the when training on the clean
data is different than the labeling when
trained on the uh attacked uh data
okay so uh the mathematical formulation
uh goes goes at as follows is that uh
for the Target node uh V I want to learn
the gcn over the original graph um and
uh I'm going to use this C star to be
the predicted class of the gcn that was
learned on the original um uh unattacked
uh
data um then the attacker comes and
manipulates my training data so I'm
going to so what I what will happen in
that case is that now the the the
network that I'm going to learn the
neural network parameters are going to
be different I I will learn this Theta
star Prime um and also because now
parameters are different the the label
the predicted label for that node V
might be different and the attacker what
they want to do is they want to change
the prediction after the graph is
manipulated from you know one class to a
different CL class okay that's the
that's the
goal so um how do we formalize this
right the way we formalize this is we
want to identify the amount
of um uh uh likelihood or the confidence
the model has in one versus the other
label right we want the probability of
the log probability of the of the new
newly predicted class we want to to
increase this term but we want the
predicted log probability of the
originally predicted class we want this
to be low so that it's going to to flip
this is going to be larger than that so
we are going to conclude wrongly uh
under the the new network that this is
the correct class uh for the uh for the
note so uh the way you can now write out
the optimization problem that the
attacker is trying to solve the attacker
is basically saying I'm trying to change
this Delta I'm trying to push this
probability up or this likelihood log
likelihood up and I want to push this
log likelihood down right I want this to
be small and I want this to be
large um and um I want to do this by
manipulating a and X to get the a prime
uh and X Prime um and uh the the solving
this optimization problem if you are an
attacker is very hard
um the reason is that because adjacency
matric is a discrete object so you
cannot take derivatives and then um
whenever you make a manipulation you
need to retrain your graph neural
network to see how it changes its
predictions so you have both kind of the
optimization problem as well as kind of
the scalability problem um and uh the
the paper that was published at kdd
2018 was the first one to kind of
formalize this framework which I gave
you the
formalization um and they also provided
um a lot of clever uh techniques to uh
to kind of resolve uh these two problems
and basically what they come up is this
kind of
locally optimal strategy where they in a
greedy way um try to execute a series of
perturbations and sequentially
manipulate the the graph basically
sequentially manipulate the most
promising element um to this to try to
flip uh to flip the label um and the way
they do this is they have this Delta
objective function this difference in
log likelihoods and then they basically
which indicates the score and then they
pick the perturbation that maximizes the
score and they keep picking the the the
kind of the ne the greedily best
perturbation until the label changes
okay so that's what they do yes in the
setup do we assume the attacker can only
change the
adj Matrix why not also the labels train
uh good question so the question is why
why can why are we assuming the attacker
cannot change the labels um if the
attacker could change the label then
it's easy I just change your label and
you'll be classified differently
tomorrow so that's a very easy attack uh
so now of course maybe what we should we
should do maybe if I answer a bit more
seriously right is like I think honest
like there are different attack
scenarios right here they said I I allow
myself to retrain the network I think a
cons completely reasonable attack
scenario would be that you have your ax
and Y you train your model but now ax a
and X can evolve they can change but the
model remains fixed how should I change
that to flip your label that would be
another uh another different scenario
right it would be like you trained your
fraud detection system now the question
is how do I organize my financial
transactions that go through your fraud
uh fraud uh fraud system right so I
would
say different uh formalizations make
sense here the authors pick the one
where they say you don't have access to
labels because labels are external um I
think my sense is that if you have
access to lab then it's very it's much
easier it's it's kind of easy right so
so so that's maybe the reason why they
choose this one that's a bit more
challenging structure
itself correct in this case we are
assuming the attacker knows the
structure of the model itself in all
these adversarial examples you need to
have access to the
model
uh yeah anyone
to use reinforcement train attack
because ah good question so you're
saying Has anyone used the reinforcement
learning to to train the attacker so you
could say I have a model that's a black
box but it would take you but right but
in in most cases especially in the
computer vision they assume you have
actually access to the parameters I
think in this uh in this case I I would
need to check the paper but I think they
don't really look into the parameters of
the model but they assume assume they
know what model you are training so at
least they have to have um could you do
reinforcement learning you may to learn
the attex strategy I think it would take
training would be super hard and it
would take super
long so kind of simar
toap detection ideas I can through every
single hypothesis compare it and then
choose the one that Returns the Maxum
liking sure this is just a greedy
algorithm it's just you like rather than
trying to find the optimal which you
can't you you you you um execute the
search step by step and at every step
you just do the best the best thing that
is best in that given moment even though
it might not be globally optimal okay
good so um I want to show you some
results um just kind of as a as a
discussion because I thought was
interesting so so this is setting is
semi-supervised no classific ification
with a graph convolutional neural
network graph is a small citation
Network 2,800 notes 8,000 edges uh the
attack type is uh modify edges add or
delete them um and the attack budget is
that you can change the degree of the
node uh for two so you can either add up
to two edges or delete up to two edges
um and the intuition is that it's harder
to attack a node um with a uh with a
with a larger
with a larger degree and the model is
stained um and attacked five times using
uh different uh random seeds so you kind
of see also success rate so here is uh
these are now predicted probabilities of
the target node over five different
learnings right so this is now uh you
know this is a seven way classification
um data set this is the predicted
probability uh for that given Target
node to belong to to a given class you
see we are uh we are correctly
predicting this node to be in class six
which is good the reason why this each
bar here is a different experiment so
you know it's a different training run
from a different random um uh random
starting point and because of this there
is some variance in what where what your
model converges to but the point is in
in all cases the prediction is correct
okay so what we want to do now is we
want to change the underlying graph to
make this uh to make this node belong to
class number seven you know whatever
that uh number seven is okay so uh uh
let's look how whether this was a the
model was able to do this so here the uh
after modifying just five edges in the
underlying network uh this was with a
direct adversarial attack you can see it
completely changes right so here we
modify five edges of the target node
with a targeted attack and we were able
to convince the neural network that um
the node now is of class uh
seven um if you look at kind of more
broadly the the results in this paper um
basically they find that the adversarial
uh attack is the strong strongest uh uh
attack significantly worsening the the
gnn's performance compared to the no
attack they find that randomly attacking
randomly adding noise is much much
weaker than adversarially attacking the
network and that indirect attack is more
challenging than the direct attack and
here I can interpret the results with
you here is a the classification margin
if it's negative the attacker succeeded
and um it was a um uh um
misclassification and basically what you
see is that with a direct adversarial
attack you can basically always flip the
nodes label
completely right um what they find out
that with if you add random attack this
is random edges between Target nodes and
nodes with different labels um you you
don't random doesn't even work even
though you can uh you can do a random
targeted attack so you can attack the
target random manipulation doesn't do
much sometimes it flips but most often
it doesn't so in this respect gnns are
quite robust to random noise either on
the target node uh or uh on the um uh or
on the uh uh uh nearby nodes and uh here
is the adversarial indirect attack and
you see that this is not really
successful right that uh indirect
manipulation is uh is much much harder
and of course it remains I think an open
question what could you do with
adversarial indirect attacks and how
would you be able to manipulate the
network um in the vicinity of the target
node to flip the Target that could be
quite uh cool if you could uh master
that okay so um let me just summarize
what we um what we studied in this last
part of the lecture today we studied the
adversarial robustness of graph
convolutional neural networks applied to
semi supervis node
classification I showed you I basically
we formalized the problem talked about
direct and indirect attacks both on the
graph structure as well as the note
attributes um and I showed you kind of
some experiments that uh that are
suggesting that targeted attacks are
easy and effective random targeted
attacks are not effective and doing
indirect attacks um is uh is very um is
very hard so um in some sense uh if
somebody wants to manipulate the target
they can easily do that uh other types
of manipulation seems to be much harder
to pull off which is um very uh very
encouraging and also I think what is
encouraging is that this random noise um
GNN seem to be quite robust to it um so
um with this um I am uh I'm done for
today